[Musique]
ça c'est vachement bien je sais pas si
vous connaissez c'est les intra to prove
wireless c'est toujours dirait du lot
c'est toujours dur à dire toujours dur à
dire trouve wireless deux sénateurs
c'est ça la mode homme fait par ces
miles or les trous wireless cette fois
ci j'ai ri sont des intra très haut de
gamme sont les premiers intra près haut
de gamme sorti par sennheiser alors ses
analyses et ses marques depuis très
longtemps depuis mon premier job si vous
le savez pas et pour la petite info
j'étais technicien songé comment faire
tant qu'assistant studio donc senna isr
j'avais des micros ses nageurs j'ai pas
mal de matos et c'est vrai que c'est une
marque que j'ai toujours et bien aimé
dans le domaine de l'audio et là c'est
vrai qu'en se retrouvant avec ce qu'est
ce que la grand public enfants tout cas
avec eux c'est un train grand public je
dois reconnaître que je suis vraiment
extrêmement bluffé et pour plusieurs
raisons
[Musique]
ces désordres nous fait une promesse de
noter là dessus je vous la laisse est
marqué sur leur site les écouteurs haut
de gamme trouve ailleurs l'ex de senna
heures ce sont des performances sans
compromis une technologie de pointe et
un design raffiné
on va commencer par le design raffiné
moi j'aime beaucoup cette petite boîte à
j'aime beaucoup ma petite boîte j'aime
beaucoup cette boîte boîte qui fait
office de chargeur vous avez 4 heures
d'autonomie un peu moins de 80 en
réalité dans vos petits écouteurs
trouvailles en laisse et avec ça vous
les recharger deux fois deux fois quatre
heures 8 heures plutôt bien ça marche
bien c'est sympa ça se recharge en usb
type c derrière
j'aime beaucoup cette retouche est issu
à fin juin que la boîte est un peu
grosse lorsque vous voulez venir la m
par exemple ici là dans votre pantalon
ça vous fait quand même une jolie petite
bosse c'est pas hyper hyper pratique
donc ça ça ira mieux dans un sac pour se
balader mais c'est vrai que dans une
poche pour moi c'est pas hyper adapté à
côté de ça les fait tissus et bien vous
venez les mettre à l'intérieur ça se
recharge directement ses pratiques ses
liens les écouteurs en eux mêmes sont
bien vous avez un côté un peu métal sur
le dessus en tête sont des boutons là
que vous avez vous êtes toutes les
connectiques qui sont plaquées or ça
marche bien c'est sympa et en plus ce
qui est vraiment bien alors au delà du
design c'est du côté pratique on vous
l'indiquait lors des procédures via
l'application de sage et vous
l'expliquer dans quelques instants pour
la mettre dans votre oreille il suffit
pas de la m et hop a les dents en fait
vous la mettez et vous mener la vie
c'est qu'en fait vous l'amener dans
votre oreille et vous venez faire un
petit quart de tour comme ça ce qui fait
que ça vient vraiment comme la crau jeté
à l'intérieur de votre oreille et c'est
vraiment vraiment cool parce que il ya
une vraie belle tenue
ils vraie belle stabilité si vous voulez
faire du sport en extérieur alors
normalement c'est pas donné pour aller
faire du sport à l'extérieur mais si
vous voulez vous pouvez regarder
alors je vous faire un peu de pain du
pogo ce que vous voulez ça tient super
bien en plus de ça il ya un autre point
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
l'isolation passive parce que ça vient
complètement vous isolées de l'extérieur
en tout cas ça vous permet donc
d'écouter de la musique tranquillement
même dans les transports bruyant je
pense notamment à l'avion transports en
commun ça nous coupe un petit peu du
reste du monde c'est pas mal
alors vous avez un mode rassurez vous
qui vous permet de vous des coupés du
monde extérieur vous avez forcément des
micros pour moi c'est notamment des
appels avec vous mes droits là vous êtes
de travers vous à 20 mois qui s'appelle
le mode transparente et louis qui vous
permet de venir vous
ouvrir en tout cas selon l'extérieur
lorsque vous avez vos deux intra dans
les oreilles que vous aurez sont bouchés
passivement
eh bien ça va activer les micros pour
vous permettre d'entendre ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur soit lorsque les
intras dans vos oreilles sans aucune
musique ou alors lorsque vous allez
écouter de la musique
le résultat au final est pas mal c'est
en tout cas extraordinaires mais ça vous
permet un petit peu notamment dans ce
que vous allez faire du footing de vos
rencontres un peu de ses passe autour de
vous et il ya un côté un peu moins
dangereux notamment pour entendre les
véhicules donc ça c'est plutôt cool dans
la boîte vous avez un cap tailles
différentes pour les intra pour venir
les régler à l'oreille de chacun ou de
chacune qu'on verra tous les mêmes forme
d'oreilles fatalement bien il faut bien
trouver le format qui vous correspond le
mieux
donc point de vue matériel en tout cas
je trouve que ils sont vraiment bien
fabriquer le fait de venir un peu les
vices et dans l'oreille ça va vraiment
vous boucher mieux les faire tenir et
croyez moi dans le monde de l'intra ya
des choses qui tiennent belote c'est un
petit peu moins ça là ça tient bien dans
la boîte
ça va parfaitement bien cémenté ça se
rechargent c'est rapide c'est bien c'est
pratique tous en usd sais c'est plutôt
cool
en plus de ça c'est un crasson résistant
aux éclaboussures donc lorsque vous
allez faire votre sport à l'extérieur ce
n'est qu'un peu petite goutte d'eau ou
un peu de transpiration
ça m'a quand même relativement bien se
passer vous pouvez bien évidemment vous
dire qui tu es de la musique ça me
paraît quand même relativement normal
mais passer des appels et gérer en plus
votre assistant vocal google assistant
amazon avec ça sans aucun problème
maintenant il importe il perd important
c'est la partie qualité audio et croyez
moi là dessus j'ai été particulièrement
bluffé alors je connais le travail fait
par sennheiser au niveau de la qualité
le doze en expertise qui est énorme
c'est au niveau des casques ou alors au
niveau bien évidemment des micros et là
dessus ils ont mis tout leur savoir
faire
on est petit en cra et c'est vraiment
bien alors on n'est pas que sur des
petits seins traoré ce en dépit d'un
train à 299 euros
on est tout de suite en haut du panier
au niveau des intra mais le boulot qui
est fait est vraiment bien
vous avez quelque chose d extrêmement
bout c'est pas quelque chose d'agressif
vous avez un ce pacte est vraiment très
lâches et qu'on vous dit très large
c'est très large vous avez un aigu qui
est très fin très doux très fin des
belles âmes qui sont hyper agréable
lorsque vous avez des voix vous écouter
des voix vous avez une sensation quand
même avec des compresseurs aux biens
comme des miles et des choses comme ça
c'est très doux il sait tous les cas
récents fait c'est vraiment la sensation
que j'ai c'est vraiment sortir un beau
sont compressés au niveau des voix c'est
vraiment super bien
vous avez des graves qui sont présents
et qu'ils sont beaux qu'ils sont ronds
qui sont pas trop bas veut c'est
vraiment bien en termes de qualité et
vous allez vraiment un truc qui envoie
un peu de gras j'ai bien une grave il
est présent il est là donc ça c'est
vraiment chouette et j'écoutais
plusieurs titres de morceaux musiques
classiques du hip hop
j'écoutais rammstein et pas mal de
choses et dans tous les cas contre
vraiment ce spectre qui est vraiment
très large très beau très doux très
cohérent et ça c'est cool
donc ça c'est vraiment le gros point
fort de ces tee intra je trouve que il
ya une belle qualité sonore une vraie
belle qualité audio après c'est le
minimum qu'on vient demander là dessus
et c'est d'ailleurs sur un produit à 299
euros
c'est la base de la base vous avez une
belle spécialisation vous annonçons qui
est maîtrisée ça ne serait ce que pour
une expérience audio complètement
optimisé je ne peux que vous les
recommandés en plus d'un autre qui est
vachement cool c'est la technologie
qualcomm a pété x low latency qui
incorporait alors qu'est ce que ça vous
fait tout ça si vous voulez le rpt x ça
va vraiment vous dire vous apporter une
meilleure qualité audio et surtout le
low latency fait que vous n'allez pas
avoir de latence entre ce qui va
s'afficher sur votre device votre
smartphone le mien je ne sais même pas
où je le laissais à elliott qui jouait
tom le chat donc entre ce qui doit
s'afficher 120 smartphone si vous
regardez une vidéo netflix et hulu ce
que vous voulez vous n'allez pas voir de
latence vous n'allez pas avoir en gros
quelques petites microsecondes
millisecondes voire carrément une
seconde de décalage entre ce que va
s'afficher à votre écran est ce que vous
allez entendre dans nos intra ça s'est
souvent cas avec pas mal d'intras dès
que vous arrivez sur les collections
bluetooth vous avez une latence avec le
qualcomm a pété xloud à peine si vous
n'avez pas de latence et ça croyez moi
en terme d'expérience
c'est vraiment génial le tonneau mais je
vous ai dit elle est très bonne vous
avez deux fois quatre heures enfin un
petit peu moins de quatre heures mais
dans l'absolu ça marche parfaitement
bien c'est vraiment cool vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 pour l'appareil est très
rapidement très facilement ça marche
aussi super bien et vous avez un point
qui est vraiment cool lorsque vous
mettez vos deux petits intra comme ça
hop le premier et le deuxième parce bon
il se met directement marche
celui-ci à droite c'est le maître est
celui-là c'est l'esclave façon de parler
lorsque vous enlevez le deuxième
esclaves pas que vous écoutez une vidéo
sané la poste directement donc ça c'est
plutôt cool à côté de ça si vous voulez
passer un coup de fil comme celui-ci et
m vous pouvez appeler directement avec
uniquement votre oreillette de droite et
pas lauriers de gauche maintenant il ya
deux trucs que j'aime un petit peu moins
elle le premier truc que j'aime un petit
peu moins c'est les commandes tactiles
parce que je trouve pas ça hyper
intuitive
ce sont de nouveaux codes vous pouvez
les à prendre une fois que vous les avez
appris et maîtrisé ça marche bien mais
je trouve ça hyper hyper intuitif alors
vous explique le truc en fait les deux
zones grises que vous avez là ce sont
deux commandes tactiles chacune ont leur
propre fonction et me faire des choses
différentes
lorsque vous allez arriver sur
l'oreillette de gauche vous appuyer une
fois ces lectures et une autre fois
c'est possible jusque là vous paraîtra
pas forcément très compliqué ensuite
lorsque vous allez à pied deux fois ces
morceaux suivants trois fois morceau
précédent
et lorsque vous le tenez appuyer sa va
réduire le volume de ce que vous êtes en
train d'écouter sur la partie droite
c'est différent vous appuyer une fois
votre assistant vocal va se déclencher
et si on vous appelle vous allez pouvoir
décrocher si vous appuyez deux fois sur
la partie droite
vous allez rejeté un appel lorsqu'on va
venir vous passer un coup de fil
et si vous appuyez deux fois et que vous
n'avez pas un appel qui est en transe à
activer la fonction find sprint et ring
c'est mal me lasser un lieu et lorsque
je vient appuyer ici sur un appui long
ça ne permet d'augmenter le volume
enfin voila je trouve que c'est un peu
compliqué c'est plein de choses à
apprendre plein de choses qui sont pas
forcément hyper intuitive
après ça marche c'est cool mais c'est
vrai que comme ça au premier abord il
faut s'y faire
ces dessins vous propose une application
qui vous permet de connaître auprès des
informations directement sur vos un
train c'est cette appli là alors c'est à
pile elle vous apporte deux trois
bénéfices déjà vous connaissez le niveau
de batterie de vaud entre à ça dans
l'absolu c'est plutôt pas mal
vous avez votre mode transparent tearing
loyer s'il est activé oui non et vous
avez un équaliseur alors le kw à 10
heures pour moi ça a toujours bien
d'avoir des écoles isr parce qu'on va
pas tous écouter de la musique de la
même manière et puis pas vouloir avoir
les fréquences de la même manière mais
je trouve pas hyper pratique là où vous
avez sur beaucoup d'application des
équaliseur par band vous allez pouvoir
régler vers un kilo de kilos de kilos
sans être tranquille aux quatre kilos un
bref du plus grave au plus aigu
là vous avez un espèce de truc qui
pourrait paraître assez intuitif vous
voyez vous avez système de deux boules
vous avez les fréquences ici les plus
graves ici les fréquences les plus aigus
et vous venez déplacer votre boule voyez
ça va changer votre spectre et après
vous de régler comme vous voulez donc
savait que son principe pour des cahiers
en tout cas c'est intuitif
lorsque j'y connais absolument rien
audio acquis que les schismes les
absolument rien et gabriel mais plus
grave plus aigus ça me corrige c'est pas
mal mais pour moi c'est assez un parfait
en réalité parce que
peut-être moins c'est une déformation
mais lorsque je veux écouter par exemple
de l'audio directement dans mon casque
d'une 15 il ya cette fréquence là qui me
dérange un peu
tiens il ya peut-être des aiguilles qui
siffle un petit peu trop je veux dire
casser un petit peu vers 6 7 kg tiens je
trouve que c'est un petit peu brouillon
dans le médium grave je veux dire casser
un petit peu vers 800m
je viens peut le régler comme ça je
trouve qu'avec l'application on peut pas
aller régler ça comme ça on a juste un
point qu'on balade et dans l'absolu tout
ça quand même relativement à sa part
fait l'application s'appelle el hassan
al zor smart control vous pouvez
télécharger sur android sur un os c'est
plutôt pas mal
bon c'est quand même bien qu'elle soit
là le truc type house mais ça marche
plutôt bien
le truc que je pourrai un peu mettre
dans la balance c'est que je dirais
aller 55 ans 60 euros de plus vous allez
avoir des casques à réduction de bruit
active heures c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas forcément la même chose qu'on
va venir rechercher entre les deux
produits mais d'un côté audio je lis
vous rajoutez un peu vous avez un très
beau casque à réduction de bruit active
notamment le sony wx1 m3 qui est
vraiment très très très bon donc je me
dis quand on a un budget c'est un peu
compliqué de refaire son sens je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez que l'on me
trouver est-ce que vous avez déjà acheté
ces petits
intrade sénateurs les mauvaises tome est
ce que voulait trouver intéressant oui
donc pas comme moi est-ce que vous
pourrez vous laisser tenter
vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire et si vous intéresse j'aime
aussi un lien en bas voilà foyer ça vous
embrasse et à demain